foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's not for your engine
ER
[Music]
here
I I got a bridge okay so I'll Bridge
boom because they're groin okay so who
took the drawing
so hot
here we go
foreign
if he has his arm uh and I was able to
be here that's the idea it's in a number
of ways I got
right or the D I caught the dude off
guard he was just standing there
normally
you see you just standing there right
sir you're under arrest you see he
starts to resist pull a minute can't hit
his head because I'm holding it up
[Music]
could be him coming in right
he's kind of oh he's trying to do his
things right
well now an hour ago he said hi
or
he goes I hit him he brings his hand up
and there is again
okay
well I would like to show though it's
not trippy it's still your Aikido
so my body's doing it
no it's not me here it looks like that
to you but he can tell it's not that so
I'm going to lock his body
his body is is in the adhesion with me
and that's what's doing it
so you
pay attention to his leg that's where
you see it on a trip that leg stays
there and his body comes around
but my body's gonna displace the leg
[Music]
okay so don't don't go to
and you're out here tripping you're
still entering you just have a sumiotush
on the elbow okay
fighting